okay thank you very much and thanks for
the invitation it feels like being a
party crasher shipping only one of two x
Mentalist here but I hope that in the
course of the talk I can show you that
there's a chance that experiments
actually can implement those very
interesting concepts and the gap
actually gets smaller and smaller
basically between theory and computer
scientists concepts and ideas and what
actually can be done in laboratory as
you can see from the title I'm Bieber
two-photon so now I would like to use a
few slides to make advertisement that
there's a reason why we still rugby
photons and I'm a fan of those nice
little guys first of all that it's very
nice to implement cubed Syrian one state
by using the polarization degree of
freedom bc basically the Bloch sphere is
the same as the polarizations here you
can address that very nicely with a
simple plate so it's actually undergrads
can do it after five minute introduction
to go to any point on the clock sphere
and we can make measurements very nice
but splitting polarization one or the
other on a cube like here you can split
them into different type so you see this
it's a very accessible qubit with
respect to many other systems the the
more tricky part is to get entanglement
and Navi use for more than 20 years the
same way to get entangled photons
because it's still the best option out
there but we do is we use a nonlinear
crystal we're basically one photon one
blue proton goes through and there's a
small chance that this blue proton is
converted into to read history of course
obey energy conservation so one blue is
the same as to-read in terms of energy
and of course momentum conservation if
you take the right crystal the focus on
the polarized you see there's one
polarization consciously other cone now
you see a picture based you look at the
crystal when the photons come out what's
a tricky part the tricky part is you
should get the same frequency guys to
say the green ones this is one
polarization state here's the other
state need to take photos from the cross
sections then you know they have to be
different but you don't know basically
which one belongs to which console you
get almost perfectly entangled states
with up to ninety nine point nine
percent fidelity to explain in a movie
what I just said now we we have
over here the ccd camera that you look
at the crystal the laser shoots in your
eye and you should tell to christy to
change the properties in such a way that
suddenly you see that this down
conversion starts happening you tilt
further on you see how the cones appear
and then when they start the overlap you
would stop there to catch the entangled
photons since we like this movie because
it's so nice to show how it goes let me
show it here basic you see this town
credit photons hey H polarize
depolarized to tip fur on and you see at
some point to start to overlap you would
stop here and catch photons from this
channel this small point here and there
to get your nice entangled photon purse
for whatever you would like to do see it
is HTS quantum computations and so on
sorry busy it is a crystal shining light
into your eyes there's a single photons
we like the smallest amount of light and
you would basically put a 5 or some
coupler to catch a from this
cross-section okay otherwise they're not
entangle because only when you get
photos from these cross sections here
okay you're able to get entanglement
because you know they have to be a
falconer but don't know which way
independent fibroids yes the lens in the
fire burn that's the tricky part is the
hard part is to get to get this
arrangement that you have this situation
happening and you get them right from
there okay the crystal on the picture of
the scale that's basically few hundred
microns like half a millimeter so but
this one is like this is like a couple
in 25 micron fiber so it's it but it
takes an experienced but people nowadays
know how to do it okay since i heard
from dorothy is a computer scientist
virtually should not spend too much into
into the experiments i hope we can go
slowly towards the experiments for
wrapping up photons everything in my
eyes and need system that allows to
combine basically everything that's out
there in with panting fun because you
can have of course foundational tests
which are done for many years now
variational inequalities and so on
there's a natural choice for
communication purposes because they fly
at the speed of light of course the
other natural choice for metrology
applications where can order cheap
enhancement
using quantum states of life and now for
roughly 10 12 years keeper realized
there's a scalable approach in principle
there you can use symphonic systems for
making plans and computations how do you
make your gate operations basically by
measuring extra photon as shown here
which process your your your your your
your input States through the
computation the finger have not realized
until I met Adam Jones on is actually
the also can combine them with different
directions which media for example can
combine communication and computation
purposes because they're mobile so you
can use fulfill it is a key feature for
starting like cloud computing the
delegated computations so until I met
these guys my understanding was
basically like this of the comic about
cloud computing so just briefly just
about gmail and yahoo but then then we
even basically when I made the first an
elevator workshop I was fascinated by
this line fountain pens and computation
and then very soon afterwards we hit
that first meeting with the fury shins
who who proposed this theory model here
in Edinburgh others and broadband LM
crochets and true Fitzsimmons they
basically the first interaction between
experimental Eastern computer scientist
irritations it took some drinks actually
to realize yes she's a few photons in
behind you actually can do something
they turned other words like a
three-year project until we got the
final resultant it was a very
interesting role that both sides against
could learn a lot at least my side and
was very interesting to see how how
things work in the other side of the
field okay thanks to Joe can make this
rather brief so that you have blind
function computing if you combine
probably the benefit from quantum
cryptography in front of computing you
can also map this in this kind of
dedicated computationally says a client
selling something just tiny classic tiny
cramped information the computer he
makes entanglement makes
measurement tense information back the
point is the computer is blind it
doesn't know the input for the
processing and know the output this is
done in the fitment of this measurement
based quantum computing which is one of
the few main avenues how you can put the
quantum computer that's the circuit
model a of AIDS in here very well in
this case you make basically the
entangled research data and make
measurements basically to process few
you know your information so I will
rather shorten that up because to give a
nice introduction you just for curiosity
might see that X mentalist explain
things differently than theoreticians so
we reduced into the number of equations
and run red with pictures so for me in
the simplest explain quantum computing
is you have to this plus States you're
hanging them by cephas operations to a
cluster state you make measurements one
by one according to not shown here on
this XY plane and you see the first
class state is rotated according to the
measurement setting followed by hot
amount to here and so on and this was
done the first time roughly ten years
ago with also four cubits they can see
depend on the shape of the cluster
one-dimensional class do you make one
cubed rotations it's two-dimensional
because you get two dimensional gates
and so on the point is what I also
learned from this blind funded computing
is that very nicely you can split the
quantum in the classical part in a way
that the phantom part is then tell you
and resource basically the class estate
itself where is the structure
one-dimensional two dimensions on as far
as the measurement settings here are the
classic informations that we find the
quantum computing ok the point is of the
of the splined quantum protocol is to
hide those two information and make it
short brickworks if you build out
everything out of bricks then you can
take a snapshot and you don't know
what's going to happen because every
brick can implement all the ingredients
for universal quantum computing you just
need to choose the right measurement
settings so the trick now is how to hide
the measurement settings basically by
adding one degree of freedom zon other
qubits can have this one of the paid
phases option here
the computer makes the cluster state but
doesn't know which kind of class the
state makes measurements again another
point is to computer knows the
measurement setting he's doing this
Delta it doesn't it doesn't notify each
only the kind knows this is a tricky but
that's the point for taking this one
blind in the nutshell that's how the
protocol goes and we go to the
experiments 9 prepares those those cuit
of a random face tenses to the computer
it makes entangled state computer gets
the orders what to measure it gets
results census bag basically only use
the client that has the benefit to know
basically what's foots what was done in
the computation so experiment so when we
have to only heard about this protocol
they said yes it's great it would like
to do it and then of course comes the
first negotiation pot so what's the
minimal effort we have to do because
everything is hard you know like we had
four cubits in a laboratory met some
constraints of the setup you know
turnarounds over take one year basically
an experiment at least at least 20 mmm
something stronger so you could
negotiate that actually to encoding two
of them are sufficient to show the
benefits yeah so we could achieve
applied optimized client funds and
computing behave interesting cater 2 and
theta 3 in the client configuration
that's the setup so where the dumb
commercial source here's the client part
where we can choose the settings here
for for those four input States and
again entanglement quantum computation
is happening at team split those optical
elements but the computer makes you the
cluster states for the blind justice it
performs the measurements I prepared
some movie which shows basically this
part of the setup in addition of the
second gate so we used they don't be
used this part will effectively once
seen off and then we added another see
note but that's not so important that's
the picture for the updated set up the
point would like to show you what kind
of space is needed so for justice blind
kind of computing that's basically space
for implementing the the dedicated
quantum computation then later on the
edit this didn't park for a second see
note gate it's not important but I would
rather show you just eclipse with an end
what down conversion works so what you
see now is that our down conversion
crystal fast days and shoots through
like this blue laser that pairs either
forward or backward emitted it's a
different experiment so don't be
confused about the nomination able to
start but the experimental setups after
summer looks the same so if person one
way the center day is a black we consent
hairs also in that way sometimes happens
to come out at the same time which is
what we want to get for photon
entanglement we shoot with 80 million
shots per second so you see many photon
pairs and other principle along this way
and that way and the tricky part is to
align that the single photons overlap
coherently a team splitters need one
guys measured you effectively
introducing gate operation which is a
c-note in that experiment so after the
first you know two photons continue
traveling go through this wave plates
that define the spin state basically
local operations you see the spin is
changing it it's cute and then again the
overlap again in another view speaker
and I measured at the end for making the
final gate but that'sthat's basically to
do for living in the laboratories to to
make some experiments happening okay
not the latest the kicker is sort of
Princeton Europe and across the state
here so this until it's great they
usually up yep especially how it goes so
the cluster state is I mean it's sort of
flying around yes precise than the
Taylor oh but say so when you're running
this protocol the server is preparing
the cluster state so yeah it's in these
photons yes yes and then at some point
it receives or some instructions yes
inertial times could be caused to fly at
the speed of light it but is so what you
do is fee but sorry interrupted videos
different question well like you so of
course he make it simply simplify as
much as you can do things we can change
shot for shot but then you have to be
used very fast switches for doing that
so what we've done is Alice had one
switched 11 setting and then the Bob the
computer was for yet another setting
made some kind of made some Browns and
collected data in a different setting
different setting the other side so of
course it was hot chocolate in Prince we
should fluid shorter shot but it was not
done like this of course huh can you
keep the cluster state sort of flying
around for ya so instead of his very
sure wouldn't behave so we can we can so
once it was Alliance and we had our
sweet spot it was running on basically
weeks we got data for all possible
settings to really mentioned until it's
dead basically get all information art
we could get from for 26 days you
basically fortin's generate then you
measure so that the state itself is
basically destroy because you measure
all the time you know but you make new
ones wrestling fans will make so it's
not the same photons will be no no
because the tony is a decreases you're
gonna get to the APD in the don't that
that was okay okay
correctly that you don't actually
communicate between a lesson book but
you look like LSA what you would
communicate and Bob guess what Ellis
would say and then you discard the
rounded roof it didn't match instead
essentially what you do don't understand
so the Ellis does not actually send to
bolt he sends the qubit there okay yeah
but but not the classical information
you know and you Bob just guesses
whatever sense and you in a sense
discard the experiment if it didn't
match up no basically so it was
prearranged waiting Bob could have got
the order to met to get it to guess if
you message but so sad but now we said
okay for this time we put this setting
there so we I live like half a meter of
table so they make your fast
communication speed up that was the
point we want you to show that when a
prince of the sweatpants on the down-low
example if you because of the extra
review if you would try to scale it do
you have like several music each time
needs communications yes then you come
to this so but no way that just has the
probability that the computational work
goes down exponentially both today but
it's one that we could to its vector as
we talked about his feet forward and
guess who communication we could have
done that and we had actually be found
there but now he was focusing on on this
on the first step towards this destroy
the future we're going to do this really
like giving orders implementing
feed-forward operation and so on this
very level so the book would become
bigger and bigger so that to match the
because the between Alice and Bob days
at the time that means you can slow it
down the tricky part for this if they
fight if they go in fiber is the only to
third to speed up line so you can still
have a casa key benefit to say okay by
the traveling there you can tell what
pay please prepare be prepared to make
this measurement so this can be done but
you know this already took so long to to
compile it's on screen but to understand
how we can implement this in a
laboratory took some time and I said
okay that's that's our focus are they do
it and then every overhead is considered
this student now we plan to do it of
course but some point you have to decide
what's the first step you like
okay I'm well that's basically it so we
took our for photons and play around in
this client function computation scheme
so you see these two are black used to
be blind so you could hide one cubit
rotations if used to apply it you could
hide those 22 betrayed operations we
could implement also like Deutsche chose
a budget agreement global search
algorithm in a blind fashion so you see
this other the hours of measurement not
for one round but just to show it took
me like all possible settings and
interested in studying as much as we can
of such an interesting computation
another thing that interestingly and
learn from the experience was that
sometimes people ask you well they know
the theory like Bell test hurt was also
the same case for the years ago you know
the fear and fury seems to be right by
right by to bother to make an experiment
okay and then the thing that we learn to
at least I learned and I guess they
would join at a new already advanced was
that wire the experience itself and then
also from feedback from referees
actually provided it's more secure than
I thought the most secure mean that if
they have imperfections that we had you
know computers are not perfect you have
not perfect entanglement generation then
what's what's basically jeopardized the
historic that is their correctness of
the computation but naughty security so
it means the clients they can preserve
food security is privacy as long as if
they're haters a random the thing was a
very interesting thing to learn that
these s pictures that ha strongest
protocol actually works in real-life
conditions and with less demanding i
meant that it was shown that by being
such a hard negotiator to make it simple
for our experiments that you don't seem
to don't need to make all of the cubic
spline you can find cases or scenarios
we can basically limit the amount of
nine qubits which all just a big benefit
in real life applications so in the
future have this kind of dedicated come
to computation is my dream to the goggle
distance and hopefully in the future you
can show me a know that we can cover
some kind of kilometers for this
dedicated other complications okay
that's the obvious thing security and
privacy preserving features the thing
was not aware of which is also like a
new baby for me was the idea of
inductive proofs and verification finds
and computations where this plant
computer seems to be very nice approach
at the moment a very resource efficient
approach I'm 22 to get an idea what's
happening in the machine and it goes
back to the toilet and on a vine that's
basically how I heard about the first
time of the scranton verification ideas
but since you had this planned panting
computer we went along this line with
joe Adam implement basically strap us as
Joe mentioned in our case again get four
cubed so we had to find some some
optimized protocol would you have done
is you didn't place the track y cubed
isolated from the others rather prepare
to trap qubits for making measurements
on those two three and then be check is
this resulted correct not correct
basically by comparing what the computer
is telling us you see we had pretty good
I'm results and see that's real life
conditions so we're going to get those
numbers or ninety-one percent success
rate what does it mean so then comes the
hard part for for them to say yes that's
a serious proof we can show that this is
it that makes the statement was just
just noise but at the end it turned out
and it's a pretty good sign parsley
place to travel different configuration
so you could shown a nice way to how
this verification idea works since since
it's a small system we we cannot place
the traps in a big computation that
rather i put it basically like as an
alternative round either you make a
computation if you're four cubits or
verification and so on that was the idea
of this off to some quantum verification
if single fortunes i'm basically opening
the eyes that this is very interesting
concept for forgetting idea what's
happening in the machine we we had also
debates about what needs to be shown and
there's an interesting difference of
opinion so from coming from quantum
physics and being like Indiana with
foundations and ten momentum pellinni
qualities before that's the only way to
prove appendicular works properly is to
make it hidden belt test okay which was
the topic of the day have you learned
that for computer scientists sometimes
it's even better to make
to say can we trust the machine is the
machine running properly and from that
automatically follows that the
differential computer you can also pay
any college if you want so but there
seems to be some some some different
opinions about what concept but what's
nice official never mind we showed this
kind of flight Belfast where the
computer got the input States he
intended them the ontology is doing this
you need all the measurements in a blind
fashion which means you had no idea that
he's preparing bell curves and making a
CH SH inequality within this
verification process ok the last 10
minutes would like to to raise questions
for total different stories that lower
change gears I'm the question is can we
apply verification concepts to this new
hive of intermediate or resource
efficient plant and computations and
what a minute that never explained
briefly both these research efficient
computations are about so Scott's basing
star I've got to talk to about the
theoretic concept it's about posing same
thing for example so for that photons a
very neat system as well that years you
can actually very efficient implement
unitary transformations to photo so if a
photon comes in one of those input ports
and you have those complex
interferometers they are just beams beam
splitters and phase shifters you canif
it effectively and efficiently map the
input state to an output state so if you
be modern guide and use wave guides and
you have those molds a few splitters
they can adjust the unitary
transformation so the hood of the task
is how can you put your I can transform
your input to an output state if you
consider the simplest case which I guess
many of you have heard a couple of times
already it says the beam splitter they
have a fifty percent chance the photon
comes to be transmitted or reflected now
you say the task is I put a detector
here and there watch my chance to get a
coincidence that those two different
output ports we get thick and then
becomes this famous kind of interference
effect also called home Emmanuel effect
where you will see that the chance that
both photons are transmitted and both
are reflected if your syrupy cuz when
arrived on the beam splitter matrix
you see that those terms to the ones a
nd plus those terms here cancel because
there's an I phase shift for each photo
minutes reflective surface okay so this
kind of interference effect needs to
very nice feature that this can
explained by the permanent of a matrix
you see the plus sign actually by the
permanent squared the point is to make a
charge it's very hard to calculate
permanence it's a case of sharp P and
what Scott has shown that actually even
related things like sampling which means
the photon comes here and it propagates
through just same thing is very hot
because it's related to the permanence
before the circuit so make it short
because call different pocket at the
last day about is requesting direction
the finger was so mind management mind
shaking fast explain the distorted in a
deal case which never which is never out
there just 20 photons and follow the
most like at the size of the unitary the
principal would outperform any class
even machine and it's great means
something you see like there's a machine
out there or some sample out there they
don't need anything no to be with kids
is they get just photons which is
frankly not so much and a complex
interfere meeting which is not that hard
not a ton realistics of my eyes such a
concept is among the best if not the
most feasible approach to really set the
benchmark came in 15-20 years from now
see there's a result of there be no
classic with Lincoln can basically
Arafat is anymore okay which opens the
interesting question extended of the
extended church Turing thesis or is
their complexity elements out there that
that basically will not allow this
planting computers so there for that
reason for groups simultaneously jumped
on this interesting research also we
have done an experiment so that these
five modes what's the first non trivial
thing to show you take three photons
okay so we but free photos in there this
is the real picture of the circuit
because I output distributions of the
same stuff was done by the groups in in
Oxford and revived Brisbane we've got
together and fabulous gear in room of
course they have this very nice simple
scheme or simple concept to something
region basically outputs which cannot be
because the computers how can you be
sure that the result is right okay and
Prince in particular as it's very it's
an entirely passive system is a passive
network so there are no gates there's no
way to make this this kind of
interactive proof because there's
nothing there so then rise the question
what can but can be set in a classical
way so as soon as the papers were out
about people raising questions actually
can you distinguish the output from the
boson sample to a uniform distribution
that was Jen's and then Scotty the said
yes of course with the old paper was
done there already okay that's my way of
reading that yeah very nicely but to the
point look it is it is it as difference
and then two groups basically compared
the output when you have interference in
the quantum mechanical way and totally
classical configurations the authors
have also done something along this line
but in a more general fashion we said
when we tune the investigator the
quantum ness by changing the distinguish
ability this thing we should be lit fuse
two photons which allows to correct rest
errors because there's probably no way
of error correction such a system
because it's passive no there's no way
to do something and the question is
which I hope the web a positive answer
can extend this problem to bigger
classes by considering all the
permanence after imminence as something
we are going to the sample so we've done
basically in a nutshell because just two
minutes left normally we have this kind
of situation three photos come in at the
same time to such that they can
interfere with and following the rules
of the permanent and so on however if
they're not in the flops is again
interfering because there's different
timing information to the not currently
overlapping the chance character
menendez result which is simple to
calculate however if they are like
slightly overlapping they have a mixture
both which belongs to the cast imminence
and there's interesting open question
nobody knows yet is imminent or how many
of imminence are hard to calculate and
if there's basically interesting open
question but it seems right now these
little you learn from from Barry Sanders
that that interesting hard questions
related to imminent
my little bit more bigger players out
there for sampling when it basically is
is a mixture of determinants and
subdomain is a minus sign put in the
plus and if you're some features plus a
minus in a different different values
than the other eminent this is the most
general case of that so if a sine
function which changes as you as you
design okay so just turn the terminal
opponent is extreme cases imminence well
okay so what you believe I'm physically
changed the timing the arrival time of
photons if they overlap perfectly if the
permanent case is the spot here if you
change for one of the other portals you
see I get landscapes which corresponds
to eminence same thing of imminence of
the matrix in there but if that have my
last slide so they think that sets maybe
I right now with this efficient
intermediate kinds of computations so if
people ask why don't you go from much
more photons these days because it was
asked to give some some take-home
message what's our challenge basically
all kinds of computers can be split into
three parts source the circuit and
addictions recently there was a huge
improvement for the vectors they work
very nicely found with almost one
hundred percent efficiency if you have
super conductor system is here the ports
also know prominently because you can
use as you like five optics or
integrated circuits but the challenging
things didn't have a good multiphoton
source bigotry photos of the same
properties the same characteristics at
the same time and hear all of them at
anthonys days for the lipstick which
means two photons drive source for
thorntons to same time we seen the two
hundred photons per second is equal to
six eight if to wait very long time to
get to the positive click into use them
for computations if that have to thank
that people exited the work was not me
but particular Stephanie parts for this
plan hunting computing and verification
and Max for disposing sampling and then
of course the fruitful colorations with
if cqt know Joe and
is Edinburgh here and Hum has not
particularly smelled like this and I was
like I see the look like keep you
afterwards and here's the Sun wait to
show that photons I think health
benefits compared to other systems
because of the capability to be mobile
to fly around so you can use this for
interactive proofs and so on Madhuri
open questions which I could come up
with it's like what are the next things
to do along the life experience the
verification because no let's just made
the first step but what are the obvious
loopholes are people have to consider
what about avoiding principle guessing
communication could happen but are the
next thing what about but the resources
we need to we need to come to memory can
be committed as you go down to really
classic communication so here's the
thing but what's interesting to show in
the future in experiments for the
planter box can extend this the
interesting intermediate computations to
product as a problems by considering
imminence or other degrees of freedom
that letter change for this first
computing and of course if you have such
a simple simple device how can you
verify or is there some fundamental
limit that the students gets too simple
because you have a very simple very very
special purpose simulator like I suppose
on Sam placed in no way at the end to to
verify if this inductive proofs because
there's a trade-off also it might be an
interesting question to see there's a
fundamental reason the limit if this
verification of intermediate quantum
computations if that I reach the end the
hopper could stay in time with your five
minutes and and I guess number of time
plus few patients in the lunch
the determine what a few when you have
three distinguishable photo sorry let's
go so basically when the photons are
distinguishable look here this it gets
very boring sisters to get casting
interferometer so we never to net
download them and do not overlap so one
photon comes time one other one time too
there's no overlap no interference
happening then they get basically
results that we are related to the
determinant of tits again a permanent
except now a permanent a bit
non-negative matrix the matrix of
probabilities yes so it's with fermions
you get a determinate yes it's true
Serena be in both places you get
something is very is the criteria yes
sorry arrived yeah yeah someone yes but
the interesting part was um to think of
what happens if just step partially
overlapping okay because I don't like
the imminent eruption I don't see why
you you get a determinant my disease
service my mistake system so it's as
simple as determinants so it's like a
permit yet right sorry no sister boson
the unlined posing system you're right
sorry no negative ever idea but the
picture is my service my mistake that
was like the slides are diplomates
recently like but the main processor is
this picture they have this that's a
permanent case in the middle where they
overlap perfectly I didn't say okay
what's happening if you consider the
realistic noise that there's some Intel
indistinguishability from frequency
differences overlapping so which is
happening in real life okay so then your
basic is somewhere out in this
intermediate regions where you very very
have to treat the full full picture with
imminent
I don't doubt that order me a half years
in this case I wonder if using a
different interpretation has an
interpretation and the determinant for
permanent agree it's a bit of bosons of
course there's no fermions in there but
they had this different sound of the
permanent which is then simple to
calculate you're right sorry first one
is leaking yes how do you actually sit
it into to get these pictures how do you
send it into an experiment ok so the
unitary is to help out to concord so
basically the first characterize the
unit urge to get a chip then you make
measurements to correct less unitary ok
they need to drastically the calculation
what do you expect to see we compared
basically so when you do that that is
theory of a theory says the kid if you
know if you consider this various delays
which was the heart actually curve the
paper with Barry Sanders yeah we get
this landscape and never took X then
they took the data and looked at the end
what's coming out and become be made
those six points and check our database
again agreement of the theory so what
you do is you measure basically the
output distribution is shown here which
is like theorem one side and explain on
the other side you see this is output
contribution basically agree with very
high reduced chi squared and so on if
the vetting prediction so the start of
this play place you would like to
understand the realistic conditions and
there is like photos are perfect there's
no Delta function they have a spectrum
in this and so on and moreover to be
learned that imminence also have to
calculate sometimes as hard as
permanence that we can maybe reach a
bigger class of computations by playing
around if these delays and photos let's
that's the only story
in the distribution case then the
partially distinguish room shouldn't be
an imminent either by no sorry it isn't
imminent for sure it's for sure it's a
bit some more complicated expression
that interpolates between this squared
per minute of a complex matrix and they
not a permanent of a non-negative matrix
I'm a doctor I'm not sure that it is an
imminent but whatever it is it may well
continue to be computationally hard
troponin t know in the regime of partial
distinguish ability
how much of the difficulty of generating
multiphoton sources is getting declining
correct the time you stopped at heart
because they've priced thyssel system so
the synchronized shot the shot it's the
only only painful thing is to wait okay
so we have to optimize have the
optimized to catch as many as possible
photons okay you have two random sources
you only want to have the case when both
lead simultaneously so he people spend
lot of time to be efficient and coupling
to improve detection because until these
days there's no deterministic photo
source so that's a Nobel Prize demise if
somebody in various multiphoton source
it related many applications push a
button they come out they get 5 14 10
photo stage you rock but now we're there
many approaches ideas how you can do it
but it's very hard so nature seems to
fight if hand and feet against giving
Fox states like Ziggy sharp photon
States for free that's our our challenge
you